[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de France 24 el
2023 inició con una polémica de derechos
sexuales y reproductivos en Argentina
una niña de 12 años Fue un centro de
salud en el pueblo Garibaldi y pidió
junto a su madre la interrupción es
legal del embarazo se trata de una
familia en condiciones de vulnerabilidad
y en la que el padre fue abusador
constante de la menor el hombre ya fue
detenido pero la niña que debía
presentarse para el procedimiento nunca
llegó y luego fue ubicada en una de las
sedes de la ong Católica grávida
organizaciones feministas denuncian
manipulaciones e incluso creen que hubo
un posible secuestro
sin embargo la organización gravida
también se pronunció y denunció que no
se está informando el apoyo que se dio a
la menor de la manera de vida veamos
nos vemos en la necesidad de aclarar que
el modo de acompañar ha ido por Un
carril completamente diferente al que
algunos medios de comunicación
informaron nuestra intervención
respondió ante una situación muy
concreta la madre de una menor una niña
embarazada una gestación de 24 semanas y
una patología clínica de relevancia
podemos decir que se forzó a alguien
cuando fueron las personas las que
eligieron recibir la ayuda ofrecida por
parte de gravedad teniendo las dos
opiniones y puntos de vista sobre el
tema vamos a conversar sobre la noticia
para ello pedimos la asesoría a Rocío
García garro quien es coordinadora del
área legal de la organización católica
por el derecho a decidir se conecta con
nosotros desde Córdoba Argentina Rocío
gracias a usted por estar en ellas
bueno Muchas gracias por la invitación
muchas gracias Ángela por por
escucharnos mire lo primero que llama la
atención en este caso es el componente
religioso que se opone en este caso a un
aborto legal usted debe también habla
desde un componente religioso pero con
un enfoque diferente y desde la
legalidad
Sí por supuesto y me parece que ese es
uno de los ejes centrales en los que
tenemos que que hacer esa distinción a
ver ser personas de fe no significa bajo
ningún punto de vista que habilite o que
o que permita o justamente como como
desde nosotros nos planteamos que se
permite la posibilidad de limitar
derechos no las personas de fe que
tenemos nuestras creencias o aquellas
que no lo tienen bajo ningún punto de
vista
habilitan permiten y justifican este
tipo de acciones Sí cuando hablamos de
este tipo de organizaciones al margen de
que sean o no sean religiosas lo que
hacen es obstaculizar de manera
sistemática derechos no
grávida es uno de los casos en cada una
de las provincias de la Argentina hoy
organizaciones de estas características
Lamentablemente sí ligadas a cuestiones
religiosas pero el objetivo está más
vinculado con obstaculizar con limitar
derechos y y bueno y evitar que
justamente mujeres y niñas te dan a un
ejercicio de la libertad reproductiva y
sexual completa no Bueno quiero hablar
sobre esta posibilidad que tienen las
menores de poner su voz en situaciones
como esta pero mientras que
organizaciones feministas y como ustedes
dicen que hay una obstaculización
Incluso un posible secuestro han dicho
la organización gravida pública su
comunicado de prensa en el que dice que
no se puede forzar a alguien cuando esta
persona hablando de la madre que sería
la tutora de la niña aceptó recibir
también la asesoría desde el enfoque que
la hace la ong grávida finalmente esta
niña sí tenía una tutora que es su mamá
Entonces se puede hablar de una
obstaculización
a ver varias cuestiones primero vamos a
a lo específicamente
concreto que hace a este caso en
particular que es lo que tenemos que
tener presente que es que en el caso
concreto el día 19 de abril la mamá con
esa niña concurren al centro de salud
Ahí se detecta la situación de embarazo
producto de una violación Y a partir de
ahí el estado inicia todos los carriles
legales
en cumplimiento con la ley 27 seis para
garantizar el acceso ese acceso se iba a
garantizar y tenían fecha el día dos de
enero sí
del 19 de diciembre al dos de enero se
hicieron los controles se fueron
cumplimentando todos los requisitos
legales y es cuando suenan todas las
alarmas cuando el día dos de enero no
van a esa a ese turno que tenían
asignado entonces ahí el estado comienza
a buscarlas y ven qué es lo que estaba
sucediendo y ahí detectan que estaban
retenidos sí
a ciencia cierta Cuál fue la el
requerimiento Y cómo accede gravida a
este caso concreto habría que
consultarlo con con la familia no
obstante Me parece que lo que es
destacable Es que es un modus operandi
propio de este tipo de organizaciones no
es la primera vez que pasa sí estamos
hablando de mujeres y niñas en contexto
de muchísima vulnerabilidad donde
realmente necesitan contención apoyo
seguimiento y estas organizaciones se
presentan como esto no O sea si uno ve
en el caso particular de gravida ellos
plantean que
buscan acompañar embarazos o situaciones
de gestaciones vulnerables no Entonces
es es muy compleja la situación Lo
cierto es que tenían asignados un turno
el cual ellas no pueden ir y es lo que
inicia e inicia los signos de alarma
para el estado bueno relación vos me
preguntas de qué es lo que dice la
legislación Argentina me parece que es
muy importante destacar que además
que habilita sí a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo esta semana
catorce gestación Y a partir de la
semana catorce de gestación ya si bien
no es voluntaria si retoma lo mismo que
ya teníamos en nuestra legislación desde
1921 que tienen que ver con las causales
la causaluna causal violación en este
caso como estamos en un ante una causal
violación
se habilita la interrupción legal del
embarazo simple Entonces estamos dentro
de un caso legal a su vez a la pregunta
de qué sucede con estas niñas menores no
Qué sucede con las niñas menores de
Trece años es importante destacar que en
Argentina el paradigma cambió a partir
de 2016 con el nuevo código civil y
comercial si bien
esa necesita del acompañamiento de Un
responsable mayor es la niña quien tiene
que decidir y necesita de lo que se
llama un sistema de apoyos para que den
el asentimiento en relación a lo que la
niña decide bueno eso le quería
preguntar porque por un lado una menor
de edad y una menor de doce años no
puede dar por ejemplo un consentimiento
para una relación sexual y eso es lo que
nos tiene aquí no porque esto es un caso
de violación y así se determina sin
embargo no se puede dar consentimiento
pero pero cómo pasa en el caso de que
ella sí quiere efectuar una interrupción
del embarazo es decir ahí qué tanto
cuenta la voz de la niña versus la voz
de la madre o la voz por ejemplo del
estado A ver en estos casos los
principios rectores cuando hablamos de
de estas infancias no cuando hablamos de
menores de 13 años es el interés
superior del niño sí por un lado y el
derecho del niño a ser oído eso debe
primar a la hora de analizar los casos
sí Entonces el derecho al niño a ser
oído es el el puntapié rector que no
está solo en el código civil y comercial
de la nación sino que lo vienen diciendo
los organismos internacionales sí
Entonces el derecho a esa niña ser
escuchada como primera medida y entender
cuál es su interés superior que más de
una vez no se trata de hacer lo que el
niño o la niña quiera sino de entender a
esa infancia en un contexto y favorecer
al mejor desarrollo Sí entonces la
opinión de esa niña cuenta Solo que como
es muy pequeña no puede
satisfacer los requisitos legales de
manera
Autónoma de manera en solitario entonces
requiere una sentimiento es decir que un
adulto mayor responsable que no hace
falta que sea su tutor elegal porque a
ver acá por ejemplo si no estuviera la
mamá el papá es su agresor obviamente
está en contraposición lo que ella
quiere con lo que quiere su agresor
entonces cualquier adulto mayor
responsable puede acompañar a esa niña y
puede dar esto que es el asentimiento
que es un apoyo Sí pero siempre
escuchando la voluntad de esa niña ya
después de los Trece años en Argentina
para los métodos que no son invasivos Sí
para las interrupciones de embarazo por
ejemplo los métodos medicamentos a
partir de los Trece ya pueden consentir
por sí mismas pero pero en este caso
necesita ese sistema de apoyos pero
siempre escuchando a a esa niña Mire hay
otro otro asunto que a mí me preocupa Y
es que se llegó tarde al servicio de
aborto no Esta es un aborto Este es un
embarazo que ya estaba rozando los seis
meses cuando se hizo el reporte para
entrar al procedimiento de interrupción
entonces pues aquí hay otros problemas
no no solamente el agravante de que fue
una violación no solamente el agravante
de que se cambió digamos la decisión de
interrumpir el embarazo sino que estas
cosas se pueden evitar y se pueden
evitar mucho antes no
a ver sin dudas
cuando hablamos de
embarazos de este tipo de
características por causal violación en
infancias en niñas tan pequeñas es uno
de los problemas que está la base Sí en
líneas generales cuando son mujeres o
adolescentes quienes necesitan una
interrupción de embarazo la detección de
la gestación es mucho más temprana Sí
porque bueno basta con con conocer los
ciclos de las mujeres y bueno y ahí
generar todo todo el sistema que que
inicia para detectar si hay o no una
gestación en proceso en las niñas sucede
algo diferente que tiene que ver con que
líneas generales las niñas no conocen
esos ciclos no conocen que están
embarazadas de hecho más de una vez
todavía no conocen ni siquiera
que son Víctimas de una violación No
porque no saben porque la educación
sexual integral es una gran deuda que
tenemos a la Argentina No porque no esté
legislado porque cuesta muchísimo su
implementación fundamentalmente en los
Colegios católicos privados de de la
Argentina pero en ese contexto
en las niñas el conocer el proceso de
gestación y hacer públicos su estado de
gestación aparece cuando es notorio el
embarazo lo cual genera que Que bueno
que estemos en tiempos ya como como
ustedes plantean bastante avanzados en
relación a la gestación pues mire Rocío
Yo le agradezco ya nos quedamos sin
tiempo y nos quedamos con dos temas por
fuera que son los riesgos de un embarazo
en una menor de edad en una niña de 12
años en este caso y cómo se puede
esperar que una niña menor de edad
violada en condiciones de vulnerabilidad
ejercen algún momento una maternidad o
pueda tener una vida emocional saludable
después de pasar por el proceso de un
embarazo cuando ni siquiera ha superado
su niñez Así que dejamos estos temas
para la reflexión de nuestros
televidentes a ustedes el agradecimiento
por las explicaciones que nos ha dado y
en 24 lo que haremos será Dar
seguimiento con la noticia gracias a
usted Gracias a las personas que nos ven
sigan en France 24 y nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]